oui
[Musique]
inapte soleymani la fille du général
assassiné qasem soleimani me rejoint
maintenant depuis téhéran pour sa
première interview en exclusivité
mondiale depuis que son père a été tué
sur ordre de trump
merci beaucoup zeinab d'être avec nous
permettez moi de vous demander pour
commencer le 3 janvier 2020 comment avez
vous appris la mort de votre père
bonjour merci de m'avoir invité
je commencerai donc en répondant à cette
question
cette terrible nuit quelques heures
avant que cela ait lieu
j'ai eu mon père au téléphone
daniela puis je suis parti rendre visite
à ma famille j'étais seul je me suis
rendu à la maison de ma soeur je savais
qu en irak la situation est très très
tendue et que c'était différent année 3
pas comme avant je me suis alors abonnés
à une chaîne télégramme d'actualité
irakienne ani je regardais les
informations sur ce qui se passait en
irak
à une heure du matin environ j'ai vu une
vidéo partagés sur cette chaîne
télégramme qui montrait une explosion à
l'aéroport de bagdad
j'ai ouvert la vidéo mais j'ignorais de
qui il s'agissait
et ce qui s'était passé sow ensuite j'ai
reçu un appel téléphonique d'un de nos
amis qui m'a demandé des nouvelles de
mon père j'ai répondu comme toujours au
téléphone qu'il dormait à la maison
parce que je me méfie des conversations
téléphoniques il s'est senti soulagé et
m'a dit d'accord dieu merci parce que
j'ai appris qu'il y avait eu une
explosion à l'aéroport de bagdad
et que ton père était dans la voiture
qu'ils ont prises pour cibles so how i
got
j'étais tellement sous le choc tellement
stressé
que je sentais mon coeur sortir de ma
poitrine je ne savais pas quoi dire j'ai
lui ai seulement répondu peux-tu
vérifier ça pour moi il a dit pourquoi
tu dis que ton père dormait à la maison
et j'ai répondu je me suis trompé
peux-tu vérifier pour moi ou il est que
tu le trouves et accolades aux alentours
de 5 heures du matin je n'arrivais
toujours pas à croire que c'était vrai
c'est vers 5h ou 6h en allumant la
télévision et en voyant une image de lui
que je me suis rendu compte ce qui
s'était passé depuis ce jour jusqu'à
présent je suis en état de choc
c'est tellement dur d'y croire ici au
royaume uni et dans les autres pays de
l'otan la mort de votre père a été
présenté comme une victoire
je sais que quelques mois avant cela il
était perçu comme un héros de la lutte
contre al qaïda et des shs même par les
médias des pays de l'otan commet deux
héros at il pu se transformer en
terroriste même le d'austin désigné par
joe biden pour devenir le prochain
secrétaire d'état américain à la défense
a dit qu'il s'était tout à fait
distinguer dans la lutte contre des
chais al qaïda et soudain le héros de
lire terroristes pourquoi eh bien nous
le savons tous al quaida et des
chaussons des groupes terroristes qui
ont été créées par les états unis
nous avons beaucoup de preuves
hu mon père était le seul à se mettre en
travers du chemin de ce genre de groupes
terroristes
évidemment les américains n'étaient pas
contents que mon père se soit mise en
travers du chemin de ces groupes font
pas ce qu'ils les ont créés pour
commencer la guerre au moyen-orient and
day où ils s'en servent pour faire du
mal aux gens à les priver de leur maison
de leur travail de leur argent de leur
pays bien sûr qu'il n'était pas content
de voir mon père se poser à ces groupes
et les détruire partout où il allait
vous connaissez et je connais ce mail
divulguées par le fondateur de wikileaks
julian assange
dans son exposé dans lequel jake
sullivan dit à hillary clinton
qu'al-qaïda et de leur côté en syrie ok
ok c'est clair aux dessins et assange
est encore en prison
why pourquoi mais quand c'est exposé
parce qu'il les a démasqués et a dit à
tout le monde que ce groupe terroriste
qui tue des innocents au moyen-orient
and midwest avait été créée par
l'amérique
pour eux la vie des gens innocents et
comme un jour in austen pipeau il
s'attaquait tout le monde partout bien
sûr il n'était pas content que mon père
s'interpose partout ils agissaient au
moyen-orient mon père les a détruits il
a changé les règles du jeu
i was l'a emporté chez sky alliés de
style les a détruits
bien sûr ils n'étaient pas contents et
ils ont tué facilement à un autre
endroit dans un aéroport international
i was des guest les irakiens l'ont
invité pour qu'il les aide
d'ailleurs comment ont-ils osé tuer un
général d'un pays ils l'ont fait sans
peine et ils ont dit l'avoir tué
qu'ils en étaient fiers des causes
pourquoi parce qu'ils ont tué quelqu'un
comme le général souleiman qui perturbé
leur plan
holder tout cet argent qu'ils avaient
investie au moyen-orient de mon père a
détruit tout cela robes et bien sûr
qu'ils sont contents et fiers de l'avoir
tué hand lyonnais bien sûr qu'ils diront
que c'était un terroriste reste des
causes dans leur esprit
mon père a ni les ce qu'ils avaient
créées donc c'est un terroriste lui qui
sauvait des vies innocentes
un terroriste qui le terroriste ici même
ce sont eux qui ont créé ces groupes qui
attaquent et tuent des gens face
s'ils m'ont est partout ce sont eux les
terroristes jake sullivan un ancien
fonctionnaire de l'équipe clinton a été
désigné par joe biden pour devenir le
conseiller à la sécurité nationale est
en outre si l'on en croit l'onu julian
assange aurait été torturé non loin de
ce studio vous êtes vous savez nos
spectateurs vont se poser la question
suivante pourquoi les états unis qui ont
eu les attentats du 11 septembre 2001
soutiendra-t-il al qaïda et des shs que
vous disais votre père pourquoi d'après
lui les américains soutiendra-t-il ceux
qui ont détruit le world trade center et
ont attaqué le pentagone en 2011
je dois dire que mon père considéré
qu'il était de son devoir de s'opposer à
ces forces
dawes et c'est de prendre le pouvoir au
peuple de le priver de sa liberté de sa
terre
il nous disait aussi qu'il devait
s'opposer aux états unis explique rose y
est greeting semble car c'est comme s'il
crée une sorte de virus de maladies
omniprésente everywhere arrive dans
chaque pays pour prendre le pouvoir pour
prendre tous deux n things and things d
av
ils prennent tous sains et après ils
disent nous ne savions pas pour ceux ci
nous ne savions pas pour cela et nous
allons les détruire
ce sont des menteurs ce sont des
menteurs de gros moteurs liars
mais il les paye bailly
il leur donne des armes et tout ce dont
ils ont besoin pour attaquer le peuple n
fun of people any and all yémen via
l'arabie saoudite
ils ont financé un groupe terroriste
dame ndèye armée pour priver le peuple
yéménite de sa liberté via magpies pour
tout acteur fried volé leurs terres tout
ce qu'ils avaient une d'érable
everywhere we want pwyw quand nous
ouvrons nos yeux nous voyons que ce
virus 6
cette maladie est partout in syria en
syrie et la banane au liban où ils
soutiennent les israéliens pour aider le
peuple libanais pour ouailles on cherche
a dépossédé les peuples de leur pays
déjà pourquoi seulement à cause de
l'argent
mon père considérait qu'il devait les
arrêter et il a réussi
c'est pour cette raison qu'ils ont tué
des toques mois pour dégager le chemin
way l'ecosse décarie savait qu'il ne
pouvait plus l'arrêter aimons les états
unis ni soutenir al-qaïda
le royaume uni déclare apporter de
l'aide au peuple yéménite
même si en même temps ils livrent des
armes pour bombarder le pays
waouh pourquoi donald trump at-il dit
que votre père était un monstre
d'abord bien sûr c'est lui le monstre
pas mon père ensuite je dirais que mon
père a tellement bien fait son travail
et les a tellement mis en colère
hurel singh vous voyez tous les plans
qu'ils avaient pour le moyen-orient sont
anéantis evry partout ils ont essayer
d'interférer et de nuire à l'iran ils
ont échoué
bien sûr pour eux mon père était un vrai
monstre pas de moi mais mon père étant
sauveur i say il sauvé des gens pas
seulement dans son pays
mais dans tous les pays il a fait ça
pour les gens nadja pas seulement au
moyen-orient il a détruit des ch parce
qu'il ne voulait pas que des gens
innocents en europe en europe
4 qu'ils soient tués par ce dangereux
virus
il l'a fait il s'est battu pour tout le
monde - not just say pas seulement pour
la syrie le yémen le liban l'iran
non non et 2 il l'a fait pour tout le
monde
il s'est battu pour tout le monde
jusqu'à son dernier souffle il ne s'est
jamais arrêtée et une offre des soins
fiqcs gorille il savait que c'était un
chemin très dangereux qui pourrait être
tués lors des soins et il le savait très
bien mais il ne s'est jamais arrêté
parce qu'il n'avait pas peur d'eux ce
sont eux qui avaient peur de lui
il avait tellement peur de mon père mais
non il savait comment il allait agir et
réagir
il savait très bien qu'il allait les
vaincre pour donald trump
mon père était un monstre zain gabon va
marquer une courte pause à tout de suite
pour l'interview avec la fille de
l'ancien commandant militaire iranien
qasem soleimani
[Musique]
de retour avec zainab soleymani la fille
du général qasem soleimani nous avons
déjà fait une interview avec la fille de
quelqu'un qui a été tué par washington
il s'agit de la fille de che guevara
elle a dit que la mort de son père avait
eu ni les cubains comment la mort de
votre père at-elle unis les iraniens je
ne sais pas si vous avez vu les
funérailles ce qui s'est passé alors en
iran et en irak
ça a été un moment particulier de
l'histoire
on a vu les gens descendre dans les rues
en pleurant de tristesse de colère
voulant se venger et ils attendent une
réponse mais croise parce qu'ils savent
ce que le général soliman n'y a fait
pour rude et fall down under ils savent
très bien aussi pourquoi donald trump a
donné l'ordre de tuer mon père myford so
so à fond à fond
après avoir assassiné mon père les
etats-unis ont cru que c'était terminé
mais parce qu'ils avaient tué le général
soliman ni l'homme fort du moyen-orient
mais il se trompe complètement dévissée
ils n'ont pas vu la colère dans les yeux
des iraniens people tmz ils n'ont pas vu
leurs larmes et leur peine leader
sadness à la raf tu sais et je voudrais
dire que le général soliman ni à toute
une armée de personnes qui vont le
venger face à donald trump
un des hommes ils ont tout à fait tort
de croire que c'est la fin du général
souleymane sy c'est le début de big and
under il ya un millier de personnes
comme le général souleymane sy aurait
dit prêt à se battre comme lui est même
encore plus fort que lui c'est notre
force
et s'ils y pensent qu'ils le sachent
notre peuple est uni en bo1 stade il
résistera assez dangereuse puissance
benger powers
donald trump ne sera plus là à partir de
janvier ce sera joe biden à sa place joe
biden qui dit qu'il veut de nouvelles
relations avec l'iran mais en même temps
son conseiller a récemment déclaré
vouloir une coalition anti iranienne aux
nations
pensez vous que l'arrivée de joe biden à
la maison blanche change quelque chose
il n'y a pas de différence entre baden
et trompe pas c'est la même personne ils
ont la même politique
heureusement il n'y a pas de différence
on truque charme on donald trump a donné
l'ordre de tuer mon père by may be done
la soutenir pour pâtes sont deux donc il
n'ya pas de différence
ils ont les mêmes idées et suivent le
même chemin saint louis c'est la même
personne amy mbaye
je veux dire baidhani tu es d'accord
avec obama quand ils ont créé des
chemins mais ice watch quelle est la
différence entre trump hebeisen watts
quel changement ce sont les mêmes ils
ont le même état d'esprit
pour nous il n'y a pas de différence joe
biden ne peut pas faire revenir mon père
ford et cas le peut-il non je tiens à
lot saute donc le problème que nous
avons avec les états unis
c'est leur politique elle ne va pas
changer des hauts de seine puis ce sont
les mêmes personnes les mêmes idées le
même chemin ils sont tous pire les uns
que les autres
il ya eu des commémorations partout dans
le monde après l'assassinât de votre
père par donald trump à l'arrêt beaucoup
de discours de vengeance ensuite plus
récemment un scientifique a été tué près
terran y at il plus de paroles peu de
véritables intentions de se venger pour
la mort de votre père
pour moi c'est une tragédie mais cela
m'a plongé dans un tel chagrin ils ont
tué une personne innocente dans son
propre pays
quand ils ont attaqué le professeur
fakhrizadeh dans notre pays ils l'ont
tuée sous les yeux de sa femme
comment peuvent-ils faire cela au real
ce n'est pas humain
comment peuvent-ils tuer quelqu'un qui
n'a rien fait de mal et qui travaillait
pour son pays ils ont tué sans peine
dans son propre pays
sous les yeux de sa femme while she was
set et elle était assise près de lui
wathier déjà tels faits what qu'at-elle
fait de mal
amine zidane d'où elle n'a rien fait de
mal à od comment hostile venir dans
notre pays et tué des gens aussi
facilement dans la rue sans lui pour
quelles raisons et tous les pays les
soutiennent il croise des apps parce
qu'ils pensent de la même façon avec
tous les pays occidentaux les aides
ils sont de leur côté et leur permettent
de dépasser toutes les limites de
s'introduire dans un autre pays
desseigne de même manière qu'ils sont
allés tué mon père en irak
ils ont tué ce professeur à téhéran pour
face ici on ne parlait pas du travail du
professeur fakhrizadeh sur les vaccins
contre le coronavirus nous le
connaissions en tant que physicien
impliqué dans la création d'armes
atomiques
de même on ne parlait pas du combat de
votre père contre al qaïda et des shs
nous le présenter comme un terroriste
qui tuer des américains
que voulez vous que le monde sache sur
votre paire phare l'image qu'il présente
n'a rien à voir avec celle de mon père
maison pour nous c'était un père et il a
beaucoup lu
il a fait des études c'était un
professeur d'université en égaux la
seule chose qu'il voulait c'était faire
du monde un endroit plus sûr pour les
enfants
liegault il est allé se battre en syrie
pour aider les enfants syriens une série
et gaufres de lier aller pour eux pour
les sauver vous connaissez les
événements en syrie
je ne veux pas parler de la situation
actuelle ces événements en syrie meuron
tellement triste quand j'y pense c'est
un caboteur à eau
comment mon père aurait-il pu vouloir
tuer des américains et des gens en
europe pour un pipeau et niort à eau
comme endroit cei lui qu'il est sauvé de
dèche haye 16 les oies saving dame pour
lui qui essayait de ne laisser personne
leur faire du mal
il se battait pour eux comment aurait-il
pu être un terroriste quelqu'un qui tue
des gens suivent il sauvé des enfants au
yémen qui mouraient de faim bang ha
ouais comment quelqu'un qui se considère
comme un être humain elle ne peut
regarder un enfant qui n'a pas de
nourriture à fodé kane comment
peuvent-ils regarder cela et ils disent
que mon père était un terroriste
mon père s'est battu pour tous les gens
vont mecque pour que le monde soit un
endroit plus sûr
l'histoire jugera et les gens saurons
beaucoup plus sur lui et sur ce qu'il
avait fait pour eux on accuse l'arabie
saoudite de bombarder le yémen hicham
and there is passé vous que sa volonté
de voir une union des pays du sud contre
la politique américaine a été une autre
raison pour la chine tonnes de le tuer
bien sûr mon père les déranger
sow ils ont utilisé tous les moyens
non et je connais beaucoup de raisons
pour lesquelles ils ont tué mon père ce
n'est pas seulement les choses dont nous
parlons il ne pouvait rien faire contre
mon père haddad
ils ont échoué ils ont été battus au
moyen-orient' ils étaient perdus leurs
plans ont été anéantis
so of corse alors bien sûr il avait
plein de raisons de tuer mon père réseau
et sans la moindre peine ils ont tué une
personne innocente qui faisait de ce
monde un endroit plus sûr ils diront
bien sûr qu'il y avait beaucoup d'autres
raisons pour le tuer que diriez-vous aux
soldats américains qui se sont battus
contre al-qaïda en syrie ou en irak
pourrait dire qu'ils se sont battus du
côté de votre père quel message leur
demanderiez vous de transmettre aux
journalistes et hommes politiques de
leur pays
je préfère répondre à votre question par
une autre question
je voudrais demander aux soldats
américains
pourquoi sont-ils en irak syrie
pourquoi sont-ils partout que
cherche-t-il pourquoi lésions voit-on
des halls cei
ils disent qu'on les envoie là-bas pour
anéantir des ch oui non mais nous savons
qu'ils ont eux mêmes créé des ch
pourquoi donc envoie-t-il des soldats
innocent à la mort tout df que c'est
pour eux c'est comme un jeu
faut il créer quelque chose et envoient
leurs propres soldats périr de la main
de ceux qui l'ont créé une belle mais
ils n'ont rien à faire de ces gens ils
n'ont rien à faire de leur vie des
adjots il n'y a que le pouvoir veut ma
l'argent et ce qu'il cherche dans ces
pays qui les intéresse ils cherchent le
pétrole mais ils doivent
à voir que cela ne va pas se passer
comme ça enfin pour finir certains
estiment que vous pourriez prendre la
relève de votre père quels sont vos
projets mon projet est de mettre mon
père en avant de montrer au monde que
mon père n'est pas ce que donald trump
andy voilà ma mission est mon destin et
d'asséner je crois que je dois suivre ce
chemin présenter mon père vous raconter
qui il était et ce qu'il a fait pour les
gens pauvres un manège envisage d'écrire
quelque chose sur lui à cause car j'ai
vu beaucoup de livres sur lui en anglais
et dans d'autres langues qui n'était pas
parfait mais beaucoup d'informations
dans ses livres sont fausses so donc
aujourd'hui j'essaye d'écrire un livre
pour présenter au monde mon père le
général soliman et tels qu'ils étaient
réellement absolue manie merci je vous
en prie
[Musique]